[Music]
if you could have one superpower what
would you think everybody chooses flight
you know why so they can fly away from
this conversation it was heroes right
Bailey backs who choose you
escape
Billy what are your superpowers
superpowers dude I don't even know how
to pee in this thing be humble like a
bad guy right
I'm bulletproof you're dead window
welcome for not getting robbed oh hey
stop I'm a superhero
[Music]
you've run from foster homes in six
counties I can take care of myself when
you're 18 give these people a chance
because that's what they're giving you
[Music]
this is billy batson make sure you make
him feel at home
they seem nice but don't buy it it gets
real gameofthrones around here dude just
mess around you look at me and you're
like why so dark you're just able to
foster kid you've got it all if you
could have one superpower what would you
pick everybody chooses flight you know
why so they can fly away from this
conversation little cuz heroes fly well
you need your fake family to stand up
for you hey man sorry about that
Billy Batson hope choose you
Mussa champion
hello say my name so my powers may flow
through you but I don't know your name
sir
sure wait for real
okay Shazam
really you're the only person I know
that knows anything about this Cape
Crusader stuff tonight yeah it's crazy
right what are your superpowers
superpowers dude I don't even know how
to pee in this thing get the feeling
just pin you fly if I quit your wheel
[Music]
okay why are you talking your bust are
your phone charged like a bad guy right
you have full immunity from your dead
sorry about your window you're welcome
for not getting robbed
oh hey stop I'm a superhero
you
[Music]
you